great thank you very much
so um firstly thank you very much for
having me it's a real pleasure to
present you to you today and and
hopefully just tell you a little bit
about my organization and evidence aid
and what the work we do around sharing
evidence on what works in humanitarian
crises so I thought I'd just take you
through a little bit of about what we do
and and the kinds of information that
that we get involved with I have an
insane so I'm hoping when I click this
onto the first slides as can everyone
see that can I just get a get a verbal
confirmation that's happened great okay
so so what do we need better evidence in
disasters any obvious question but I
mean the the scale of both humanitarian
need and actually humanitarian action is
is enormous and and the and the actually
the scale of humanitarian aid spending
worldwide continues to grow although the
the rate of growth is is flattening off
but the the the level of activity across
the world in humanitarian aid is is very
considerable and and the amount of money
that's spent on it every year is is very
considerable to late last year it was
around 21 billion pounds
and I think it's Elio teats and the word
the risk of stating the obvious it's um
it's a pretty high stakes to game the
the the ultimately the aim of doing
humanitarian aid is to save lives and to
reduce morbidity protect livelihood and
safeguard well-being and we're dealing
with some of the most vulnerable people
on the planet and I think that was an
enormous moral obligation on the
humanitarian community to use the best
available evidence to design targets and
execute Ximena serenade that's a really
strong mall in my view a moral
obligation as well as a pragmatic one in
that we're not going to maintain the
level of supports both funding and
political support for humanitarian
action that currently exists if we don't
ensure that it is as good as it possible
possibly can be
so
that's really I suppose if you like that
to be that's the kind of that's the kind
of big picture as to why evidence AIDS
exists why we were set up
my background I should say before I get
into further into the rest of the
presentation is I come from a
practitioner background I'm not a not a
researcher I'm not a an information
specialist my background certainly in
the early part of my career was in
humanitarian practice and I worked for a
number of large NGOs active in
humanitarian work
spending most of my career working for
Oxfam and I suppose the majority of my
experience therefore was in the kinds of
public health programming that Oxfam
generally does and we focused a list of
our work around water and sanitation
public health promotion which I'll talk
about a bit more in a bit so we have a
problem
I think in the humanitarian sector with
evidence and we don't currently use
evidence nearly as much as we should do
for a variety of different reasons first
of all I think there are big gaps in our
knowledge base around around the
effectiveness of different kinds of
interventions and underpinning our work
so a study that was done by the London
School of Hygiene and Tropical Medicine
last year in a few public health
research around humanitarian crises
found that that there were first of all
that they were very few relatively few
were bused studies that were that were
present but there was also a lot of
patchiness within the researches so
while they were 131 only there were only
eight online so so yes so there's patchy
evidence in that we have a lot of
evidence in fact on some areas and not
very much on other
and non communicable diseases one of the
big big gaps there are actually no
studies at all that were found by London
School on acute with spiritualy
infection for example which is one of
the biggest killers actually of
under-fives
in the developing world and certainly
one of the biggest killers in
humanitarian crises so we we do have
some pretty big gaps there's also a
problem around the quality of the
evidence and the same study by London
School found they need 345 out of 5,000
papers that were that research that lets
their quality standards so there's a
problem around just simply the quality
of the research and evaluation that's
being done and this is actually this
finding has been replicated by a number
of other people who've done similar
kinds of reviews so the London School
focused mostly on public health other
actors like Oxfam for example largely
replicated those findings in other areas
of humanitarian practice so it's a it's
a it's a problem across the across the
board
and one of the big one of those common
problems actually is that many published
studies don't have don't actually
specify what their research
methodologies are so they it's not
obvious to people doing doing reviews
how the data has been produced which is
pretty important if you're going to
assess the quality of the work so that
really limits the usefulness of a lot of
the research that's done in humanitarian
sector and in my view if you don't use
the research it's a bit of a waste of
money and same goes for evaluations as
well if you don't if even you answers
aren't being clear and showing they're
working as it were about how they reach
their conclusions it's very hard to
actually take that take that research
and information seriously and a final
problem which I suppose is where it kind
of intersects mostly most with the kind
of information communication world is is
just being accessibility of not of the
evidence that's relevant to the military
field so we don't as a sector it's you
know we often say actually that we don't
know what you know a great deal of
greater than evaluation in particular is
kind of hidden away on on intranets of
various organizations if you're lucky
they may or even not be not be shared
internally within organizations they
they they tend to be done they're done
for a specific purpose like for instance
a donor wants an evaluation to be done
but then it's not it's either not
published at all or it might be
published on a pretty obscure location
and not communicated to practitioners so
that really limits the use of a lot of
research for for practitioners which is
really what it's all about in my in my
view so there's really no you know some
of this I think it's just you can really
see it as is publication bias within set
so we tend to publish good news like
like many other sectors but I think
we're particularly we're particularly
affected by by this and I I like to show
I like to show this slide although it's
not specifically relevant to
humanitarian aid I think it really needs
me neatly illustrates that the problem
as to why a lot of research and
particularly a lot of evaluations of of
interventions done in many sectors but i
but humanitarian in particular and white
why that is the case and this is
although actually it's not a
particularly wonderful graph in terms of
being obvious at first like what it's
saying essentially this is a plot of a
study done by the National Audit Office
which is kind of quasi independent
Ombudsman of governments in government
spending in the UK and it it tried it
plotted the robustness of evaluations
done in the public sector in the UK now
plotting the robustness against the
assess effectiveness so how good the
projects or program was that was being
assessed and you can see that Cedars
Nimbus this member there's an inverse
correlation basically between the
robustness of the the study and the and
the positivity of the results so I the
all of us to study the worse the the
assessment of the work very often and I
think where you have as in our sector a
really strong incentive from the donor
community in particular really obsessing
over results delivered by humanitarian
actors and only funding organizations
that are seemed to be able to deliver
results very often quite low level
results list of outputs how many wells
we built or how many people have you
accessed rather than looking at really
in-depth outcomes when you incentivize
when you only ever incentivize good news
rather than encouraging people to be
open about the success or failure of
their their work then it's almost
inevitable that people throat will try
to hide examples of examples of failure
examples or examples where the impact
was either not as expected or not as not
as high as they feel that perhaps the
donor would would expect to see so I but
I so that's kind of quality and quantity
of research and humanitarian evidence in
in this sector but it's not just about
the quantity and the quantity it's also
about what we what we do with it and the
we aren't particularly marvelous within
the sector about
even where it where evidence does exist
but we're not particularly when
optically good about using it and I
think again this is about incentivizing
for me this is this is about the whole
community whether it's practitioners
researchers donors policy makers whoever
all of us need to work together in a way
that's actually incentivizing the use of
evidence in a way that that underpins
policy and program guidance funding
decisions all sorts of aspects of the
sector including the way to train new
staff and the way obviously we make
decisions on the ground the
because the kind of orange box is a
quote from a new publication that we've
put out which is an evidence guide for
practitioners can we've done a joint
joint publication with the London School
of Hygiene and Tropical Medicine and the
Nesta foundation and really a lot of
what that's about
it's essentially a practical guide
humanitarian workers on the use of
evidence but it's about how evidence
should be made it should be built into
decision making and I think one of the
perceptions we need to kind of get over
is that in some way research and
evidence is is kind of it's a it's it's
it's it's sort of dictatorial it tells
you what to do and and professional
judgment is kind of pushed to one side
but actually what we need what we what
we're really talking about when we talk
about evidence-based decision-making is
not is not that it's actually it's it's
it's actually still seeing professional
judgment as a essential to the decision
making process but that evidence needs
to take a much stronger and central
position within the decision making
process so we talk about this kind of
nexus of different factors
which I'll come on to later on I'm
painting a bit of a bleak picture so I
thought I just kind of given you the
opposite and say where I think we've got
it right in a sector in the past and
what the what the games are really so
when I was just starting out in
humanitarian aid we still did therapy
succeeding in response to severe acute
malnutrition in inpatient facilities so
we go around when there was a
particularly bad when there was
particular bad food insecurity leading
to too severe acute malnutrition amongst
vulnerable people we get to go and set
up inpatient facilities usually a tent
or a temporary structure or set up
within an existing building and we do
inpatient care for severe and severe
acute malnutrition for those effectives
which would involve setting up all sorts
of new facilities maintaining very
strict hygiene providing clean water all
sorts of things and it was pretty labor
intensive
and not always very good actually we
didn't always III saw some very good
facilities also saw some pretty poor
ones but actually in the mid-2000s a
series of studies came out actually
really show starting in the in the late
90s which showed that you could do it
much more effectively actually through
community-based outpatient treatments
using ready-made we using ready-made
supplementary food
and that this was more but not anymore
effective but also cheaper because you
didn't have to go around setting up all
the business new new facilities and a
systematic review in 2000 to show that
whew it's that severely malnourished
children were on average 51 percent more
likely to recover using these new
community based protocols than the old
impatient model so this is an example of
the humanitarian sector using evidence
in in practice and actually transforming
the way it did business in one
particular area so we have done it we
can do it we don't we just don't always
do it and actually I think I would go as
far as to say this is the minority of
places where we where we where we when
we do this when we do do it I think we
do it it has a big impact and it and as
you can see from that particular results
it's a pretty significant game if if
you're you're effectively you're
effectively getting 51 percent more
malnourished children out of out of
severely acute malnutrition than you
would be with inpatient care that's a
pretty significant game
so
what we're what we're really talking
about here I think as I was saying
earlier it's trying to kind of build
best available evidence into the
decision-making matrix and not to say
that that's that kind of when we're not
talking about people becoming kind of
automata or just kind of providing
answers in every case you've still got
to triangulate the best available that
evidence with the practitioners own
knowledge contextual analysis is really
important to know come on to that a bit
later the the pride the the pragmatic
concerns where you're working it may not
be possible to do the best the the
notionally best intervention that the
evidence is demanding because the
practical environment doesn't let do
that so for instance if you if you're if
you're if you're working in a physically
constrained site and you don't have a
choice about that you may not be able to
provide the level of facilities for the
kinds of facilities that the best the
best available evidence would would
would point you towards but you may be
able to do something else and lastly but
very much not least
two people is a really important part of
humanitarian decision-making more so I
would argue than in many other areas
because they are the most wonderful
people in the world and you're dealing
with people who are in in the very worst
conditions that you could possibly ever
hope to find yourself in as a human
being and it's contingent on the
humanitarian sector to listen to what
people want as well as simply providing
what's needed and what's worked what the
other thing suggests so we
kind of trying to rebalance the
decision-making process say that best
available evidence is a really strong
component of it but it's not the only
component teachers so I wanted to talk a
bit about how you how you triangulate if
you like global evidence with local
evidence and
while I you know obviously evidence aids
promotes a big part of our role is to
promote systematically reviewed research
and and really high quality research at
a global level you still need to look at
the local level as well in order to see
what works
so the example of watching is from my
own experience it which is kora
prevention in the Democratic Republic of
Congo in Central Africa cholera is it's
endemic in eastern DRC in particular but
actually throughout the country as well
it's just a fact of life and it's become
more and more a fact of life since the
the beginning of the the car well it's
difficult to talk about the beginning of
the war because the war has been going
on for so long and actually has been
low-level conflict has been going on in
DRC for a very long time indeed but I've
been I've been active in the
humanitarian sector for quite quite a
long time now and and there's been a
conflict in DRC throughout the whole
time I have been active much of the last
20 years and cholera has an endemic
cholera has come hand-in-hand with that
with that conflict outbreaks are really
common and in fact one last year was was
one of the most severe that Congo has
ever seen and there were 53 thousand
cases and over a thousand death the way
that the humanitarian community responds
to cholera in DRC
is quite formulaic and has been probably
like I would argue
for much of that those those couple of
decades that color has been really
prevalent in in CRC and we generally we
do
what's called wash say water sanitation
and health promotion and that's really
integral to what we - what we do and
actually there's a really good reason
why it's a good idea to do water
sanitation hygiene probation and it's
pretty well supported by the evidence
certainly some parts of water sanitation
of house information are really well
supported by evidence so chlorination of
household waste water for example with
use of chlorine tablets is pretty well
supported by systematically leads
evidence other interventions though like
building latrines
oddly enough are really poorly supported
by evidence a lot more is needed to try
and pick what are the most effective
interventions around safe explicity
disposal in relation to reducing the
risk of cholera
of the things that were in a good
example of where the sector has used
evidence is in adding to the if you like
the technical interventions that we do
the building water supplies building
toilets adding to that household based
hygiene and health promotion including
around hand-washing and that's that's
reasonably well supported by systematic
reviews we need evidence as well and
that means that that in the early 1990s
made a really big difference to the way
that the humanitarian community does
does wash in general but washing the
context of communicable diseases like
cholera in particular
in TLC
we generally do wash because almost as
an automatic response to to cholera to a
cholera outbreak so so when when there
is a car outbreak someone will come out
long and they will do you know a lot of
people do will do wash wash style
interventions often around household
water supply
but we don't really understand why and
we don't really understand
we certainly don't understand the
particular risk factors around Cora in
in DRC and we don't really we certainly
don't understand the impact that the
work that we're doing has on cholera
transmission although we often praying
we often make some of the extravagant
claims about having reduced the either
the instance or the mortality around
cholera
this hasn't really helped by the fact
that there isn't very much data at
national level so there's no at the
moment no institutional lead within the
Ministry of Health or any other body
which draws together epidemiological
data at national level on on cholera in
DRC so if you want information on
cholera you have to go digging yourself
and you have to that means mooching
around and talking to health centers and
and digging the data at yourself and
then doing the analysis but if you do do
that you actually spend the time doing
that you see that there are some
interesting correlations for example
between proximity and contact with
surface water and coral expand infection
so many of us who get sick are people to
go fishing in open water sources people
who praise their water their their
cattle in you know open water sources
women or and other people who wash
clothes and other things in rivers lakes
and ponds so there's a high prevalence
as I am at high prevalence of Cora
amongst those groups particularly early
in the early part of a cholera outbreak
so that's not to suggest we should stop
doing wash
there's a really strong you know there
is there is a strong evidence base but
it's you know if you let you take the
kind of global picture it's a good first
response there's a kind of on average
it's a it's a good it's a good thing to
do you're not going to do harm by doing
it but in this context at least we
really need to look broader based
interventions that address specific
local risk factors so for instance
should we be stopping people paying
people for example to stop fishing in
lakes and they they don't get infected
with cholera
it's interesting to note actually that
the Burundian army stopped stopped a
couple of pretty big nasty cholera
outbreaks in along the Missouri River
for the Burundian side the border in
their tracks by by just banning people
from going into the water and stopping
them physically from from going in which
is pretty which is pretty rough and and
not the sort of thing that an NGO would
be particularly comfortable to get
involved with but it worked
it stopped people from getting kora and
I think we should think about
interventions which which have a more
direct impact on people's behavior to
try and stop stop a disease like kora in
its tracks so we need to we need to
think again about our strategy and look
at a look beyond wash so I thought I
just kind of I kind of zoom out a bit a
bit a bit again and kind of talk about
John Snow who I don't know I never
couldn't they're quite whether he's some
he's as famous in the rest of the world
as he is in the UK but certainly for us
he's he's he's the kind of founding
figure of a whole range of different
professions and lines of work so he
basically in the kora outbreak in London
in 1854 he he laborious Lee when
everyone else thought that Cora was
caused by what's called miasma sore gas
bad smells he went and actually mapped
Cora instance in every Street in the
affected area of London and he figured
out that that there was a really strong
correlation between where the Cora
outbreak was occurring and the use of a
single water source a prompt in
Broadwick Street in Soho
and he actually went along and he took
physically took the lever off the pump
to stop people using the the pump on
that and stop at your source being used
and the the cholera outbreak was was was
stopped or Stoke significantly reduced
as a result and he's kind of held up as
being if you almost like the founding
father of Epidemiology and and as well
as things like Public Health engineering
there's a whole massive slew of Public
Health engineering that kind of resulted
from from the work that we did
but the interesting thing about John
snow is that he always questioned his
own effectiveness
so he actually himself at the time
question whether him taking the Neva off
the pump really had stopped the Cora
outbreak or whether it is simply it was
simply had caught a correlation between
he was burning itself out of the
population anyway everyone who was going
to die had already died was there really
a strong evidence base to say that that
him removing me believer from the pump
had actually made a concrete impact on
one Cora and I think we need to be a bit
more like like Jon Snow I think we
actually need to question our own
effectiveness more often and more more
carefully and
and and really look at the evidence base
for what we're doing and think more
laterally when the evidence is saying
that perhaps water usage is not the only
not the only show in town or or or
household based water usage is not only
in show in terms of Cholera transmission
so I thought I'd tell you a little bit
about avid evidence aid in the work that
we do so we were founded by medical
researchers who were keen to see whether
and how robust medical research in
particular could be applied in
humanitarian sector set settings we've
got really strong links to Cochran and
our primary focus really is to collect
this could circulate together systematic
reviews evidence from the Cochrane
Library and other sources and build
practitioner orientated thematic
evidence collections with clear
summaries of findings and
recommendations but and
[Music]
yes so so so
we trying to fill some of those gaps
that I was talking about and earlier on
and we engage with humanitarian actors
in a variety of different ways
so I'm just trying to move on to the oh
yeah okay and we connect together
amongst other things we collect together
evidence collections on ticking
humanitarian themes so here's an example
of a few that we've pulled together
around malnutrition Ebola wind storms
and and some other areas and they're on
a website which is the link that you see
here we also run an annual event which
is actually going on next week which
humanitarian evidence week which you're
more than welcome to participate in
there's a whole range of online events
going on over the course of next week
and the practice guides I mentioned
earlier is also on our web site which
you're very welcome to go along and
download if you'd find that useful
thank you very much indeed I hope that
was was useful and I think we'll have
some questions later on but that's
that's it for me thank you so much then
and I know we're missing you and Carolyn
too abbreviated presentation because of
our technical difficulties so I
appreciate I appreciate that if you can
drag down that green ball to Carolyn and
just we we have a we have the disaster
that database we added that practice
guide to it we're very excited to see
that come out so thank you yes so
Caroline I'm going to turn it over to
you and let you introduce yourself and
talk about the work that you're doing
over in Great Britain as well fantastic
thanks very much Ron right so hello
everyone my name is Carolyn debris and
I'm a knowledge and evidence specialist
librarian the public health England
today I'm going to talk to about two
pieces of work that PHP has been
involved in firstly I'll describe the
HIPAA Library and Information Services
project which describes the initial aims
and objectives listing our main partners
and then I'll briefly highlight our
outputs phe is involvement with the
project came to an end in March 2018 and
the second of my present part of my
presentation will describe what came
next talking about evidence for global
and disaster help and our work with if
less the International Federation of
Library Association's and institutions
so HIPAA stands for healthcare
information for all and it was set up by
a doctor called Neil packing and watch
and he wants to reduce inequality and
access to good quality information about
healthcare so that people around the
world can make informed decisions with
the HIPAA list project the aim was to
support and promote the role of Library
and Information Services in the global
and disaster health context and presenta
financial partnership projects through
an exploration current issues activities
and needs so two main objectives were to
explore the role of libraries and
information services
global and disaster health and to
identify issues needs and solutions to
help libraries and information services
fulfill their potential in this area in
addition we also wanted to engage the
helps Library and Information science
community through presentation of
project findings that's an international
conference special interest group and to
determine and scope potential topics and
areas for Phase two projects with
partners so our partners we have public
health England that's well that's who I
work for and public health England is
the national public health agency free
England existing to protect and improve
the nation's health and well-being and
reduce health inequalities it does this
through advocacy partnerships
world-class science knowledge and
intelligence and the delivery of
specialist public health services
throughout England and further afield
when needed for example during times of
disease outbreaks deploy a team to
whichever area needs to have helped
health care information for all HIPAA is
the professional Global Health Network
working in collaboration with the World
Health Organization and currently
supported by the British Medical
Association PDR which is whose special
programme for research and training in
tropical diseases The Lancet and more
than 280 other health and development
organizations across HIPPA brings
together more than 16,000 stakeholders
which represents more than 2,500
organizations across 176 countries
worldwide with a common vision of a
world where every health professional
citizen researcher and policymaker has
access to health care information they
need to protect their own health and the
health of others now I'm going to repeat
a little bit of what Ben's already said
because I want to introduce evidence
laid so evidence aid aims to inspire and
enable those guide in the humanitarian
sector to apply an evidence-based
approach in their activities and
decisions to ensure those in need
receive humanitarian aid in the most
timely effective and appropriate way
possible as Ben said it was established
following this Armenian generation in
December 2004 and uses knowledge from
systematic reviews to provide reliable
up-to-date evidence on interventions
that might be considered in the context
of natural
disasters and other major healthcare
emergencies evidence aid seeks to
highlight which interventions work which
don't work which need more research and
which no matter how well-meaning might
be harmful and to provide this
information agencies and people planning
for or responding to disasters so the
project commenced this project commenced
in March 2017 and that were starts as
good evidence-based practitioners we
looked at what evidence was already
available on this topic we searched six
databases cinahl M based global help
Lister MEDLINE and PubMed and we also
searched Google to find the evidence
around knowledge and library service
provision and knowledge management to
support global health and disaster and
emergency preparedness we specifically
looked at natural and man-made disasters
for example struggling and wildfires etc
and disease outbreaks such as Ebola and
Zika virus was looked at a conflict zone
Rita the involvement of libraries in
conflict zones using this information we
produced an evidence briefing and I will
describe the key findings in a moment
the next stage of this project was to
hold two somatic discussions via the
HIPAA forum the first discussion took
place from July and August 2017 just
before you adieu to present how work at
the European Association for health
information libraries workshop in Poland
we wanted to find out what we know about
the availability and use of reliable
information for global health
emergencies disasters and disease
outbreaks the second discussion took
place almost a year ago in October in
November 2017 it's part of evidence a
humanitarian evidence week and the theme
was what do we mean by evidence informed
humanitarian action and what kind of
evidence do humanitarians need and why
so the key messages from the evidence
briefing first of all 68 key papers were
identified and analyzed and organized
into five themes access to information
knowledge management existing programs
roles for information professionals and
social media from these papers the
following key messages were gathered
there are in times of crisis like
Ariane's can have alternative libraries
can have alternative functions they can
become charging stations for mobile
phones and internet connection points
they could be sanctuaries places to keep
warm a safe meeting point last year in
charlottesville USA the Claude Moore
Health Sciences Library at the
University of Virginia hosted a Family
Assistance Center to provide support for
family members of those injured
libraries close affiliated emergency
services to communicate messages to the
public via Twitter Facebook phone etc
they can deliver pre-departure training
to people who are going overseas to
support master teams they can administer
antidote in the USA where there is an
issue with opioid overdoses and
libraries librarians are being trained
to administer narcan to help drug users
survive an overdose and they can provide
shelter for emergency teams there have
been cases where the emergency key
emergency workers have been managing a
crisis and like we have been opening
their doors to provide somewhere for
them to rest to get food and any other
support that they need there are new
roles evolving to support emergency
teams for example at global health
information and disaster information
specialists they need specialist
knowledge such as knowledge of different
tropical disease outbreaks news and
information sources social media can be
used for information dissemination
disease surveillance and communicating
with the general public
another key message with access to
timely accurate and quality health
information for disaster teams is
essential but it's not always sure who
should deliver that information
one thing that was definitely pointed
out was that there is a digital divide
with regards to access to the evidence
but in developing countries this is not
just during emergencies that something
to be aware of knowledge management
tools are available to support global
health knowledge and knowledge brokers
can support data sharing so again and
other key roles librarians something
that hadn't occurred to me with the
awareness of local context such as
cultural sensitivities their fears
insecurities and also the inequity in
literacy levels and this current local
context is very much needed it's
something that librarians can't
because they're located in that in the
community so from the thematic
discussion one the observations we it
was what what do we know about the
availability and use of reliable
information for global health
emergencies disasters and disease
outbreaks and we received 78 messages
via the HIPAA forum coming from Ethiopia
Germany New Zealand Nigeria Norway
Tanzania UK USA and Zambia so it's
really interesting to get all these
opinions from different countries the
main finding was that there is a huge
gap between what is needed and what is
available with each player not having
the capacity to deliver to their
potential
although librarians can help bridge
those gaps so the second sematic
discussion with what do we mean by
evidence informed humanitarian action
and what kind of evidence of
humanitarians need and why this
generated 104 responses from Bangladesh
Iceland India Nepal Nigeria Sudan
Switzerland Uganda UK USA and Zimbabwe
the key messages from this discussion
were that there is no clear definition
for evidence informed humanitarian
action the humanitarian sector often
relies on lessons learned rather than
synthesized evidence we might have
general evidence but not evidence to
guide us in non-ideal settings and
different crisis types humanitarian
practitioners a difficult to engage with
through an academic pathway and
librarians could play a much larger part
in humanitarian response Ben's
introduction to the guide that evidence
I'd have just provided will probably
answer some of these questions so it's
definitely worth a look there but there
is still work to be done
although pH is informal involvement with
the project came to an end at the end of
March 2018 we are continuing to work
with his roads a core partner and pH
ease knowledge management program will
continue to explore other projects and
joint working in the field of global and
disaster health he will continue to work
with a little project working group
members to support and inform this work
if you go to the his list project you
can see all of all the work we've done
you can find out how to Jordan Hitler
behind that detail
of activities publications and members
and also further information if it isn't
just all about libraries and librarians
it is there are representatives from all
sectors disaster team workers
humanitarian workers librarians
scientists researchers all contributing
to the discussion so if you have
questions it's it's really worthwhile
sort of joining into these discussions
you've got specific questions you want
to asking in relation to the global and
disaster health so that's just the one
project but they also have several other
projects which you couldn't have a look
through and several other networks that
you might want to belong to I think
there's one on child health as well
moving on to the next slide so the next
steps we have been in talks with the
European associations health information
ibrid about setting up a special
interest group on this topic but
following discussions with other
interested party that was agreed that it
would make more sense that a person
special interest group with if Fleur the
International Federation of Library
Association's and institutions and as
part of the health and Biosciences
library section which is chaired by
professor Maria Mizuki Uganda's first
female professor of information science
in January 2018 the evidence the
globulin lost the special interest group
was convened by dr. Anne Bryce a head of
knowledge management of public health
England and in August 2018 a satellite
event and open meeting was held at the
84th world library and information
Congress in Kuala Lumpur Malaysia so on
a slide you can see a link to the
special interest group there's also a
separate page for the satellite meeting
where you can see the program and
presentations and all the resources that
we produced so the morning of the
satellite event involves a series of
presentations Virginia Murray consultant
in global disaster risk reduction of
public health England started
proceedings with a presentation
describing the role of libraries and
supporting the Sendai framework for
disaster risk reduction and again on the
slide you got a link to read more about
it we then had six presentations the
first one was on public librarians
health
the community America the next was from
evidence aid about evidence collection
or moderate and severe acute
malnutrition which is what Ben was
talking about earlier third one was
about Philippine research on disaster
risk reduction in health
the fourth describes how to use GIS data
and mapping parties to expedite disaster
relief response to vulnerable places
fifty looks at disaster metrics and
describes a comprehensive framework for
disaster valuation topologies and
finally there was a presentation on the
role of academic librarians in
developing countries in facilitating
transformation for sustainable
development although papers and
presentations are on or almost linked in
the slides here then in the afternoon we
held the finding the evidence will
global and disaster help workshop
highlighting and demonstrating freely
available quality information sources
such as systematic reviews from evidence
aid Campbell collaboration and evidence
gap maps from three ie the international
initiative for impact evaluation all the
resources that we demonstrate available
in the pad met link in a slide that's
much like meeting we also launched a
handout for finding the evidence for
global intern asked to help and again
the link to this document is in the
slides it was basically putting together
all the resources we'd identified and
it's not just the usual ones like PubMed
and EMBASE and you know but also
retrieved such a range of resources from
the World Health Organization about
training about how to do systematic
reviews videos it also incorporates
resources which we've gathered securing
the somatic discussions so it's a work
in progress
because people are still recommending
useful quality resources which are
freely available and that's the main
points makes the content as accessible
as possible
they're with me yeah so the next step
we're running a series of webinars and
as we mentioned earlier the first one
will take place next week as part of
humanitarian evidence week 2018 and you
can follow them on Twitter hashtag hgw
2018 it flür evidence the global and
disaster helps special interest groups
will be hosting the webinar and finally
eight
the global and disaster health on Monday
19th November 2018 at 3:30 p.m. GMT more
state details are in the link on the
slide more webinars will take place in
the new year and you can find out about
these or if you follow the hash the
Twitter hashtag efore G D H evidence the
global disaster help and that will keep
we'll keep you up to date with all our
progress the next meeting of the
evidence for global and disaster health
professional interest group will take
place of the world library and
information Congress the 85th if there
General Conference and assembly which
takes place 24 to 32 August in Athens
Greece
and we hope to see there to see you
there you'll have my contact details at
the end of this and we'd love if you
would contribute if you want to join or
send an abstracts would be great to have
everyone involved so I love this picture
it was taken at our first satellite
meeting in Kuala Lumpur in August there
are librarians and representatives from
NGOs from America Australia the
Philippines Uganda Spain South Africa
Malaysia and the UK this photo filled
with pride and I feel really honored to
be working alongside all of you and I do
that you will join us in this work I
think my presentation was a little bit
shorter possibly too fast a little bit
nervous but thank you very much for
listening if you do have any questions
please get in touch and do follow our
progress on Twitter hashtag efore gdh
and also the progress of humanitarian
evidence week next week hache GW h pw 2
MP 18 and if you want to find out more
but if you can follow their twitter
account which is at HIPPA underscore all
the healthcare information for all thank
you very much for listening are there
any questions
Wow Thank You Caroline and also to them
for the amazing presentations that you
do we want to let you know we do put it
in the chat box or just so people know
as always we are going to make the
reporting and the powerpoints from this
from today's webinar available on our
webinars page we'll also pull out all of
these great links they're about evidence
aid and all of the resources that those
speakers provided in the PowerPoint
slides will create a a handout so you'll
have everything on one sheet I please
feel free to go into the chat box you
can open it at the top of the page
there's a little box that says chat and
if you click on it it opens up the chat
box and it selects all participants and
you can just type in a message to our
speakers or you can unmute yourself and
ask a question on the phone I know I was
sorry to miss that first meeting and as
if a special interest group and it looks
like you had a great group of people
there and looking forward to seeing what
happens in Greece next year yes you were
very much made such but IP next year I
think thanks yes we hope to get there
okay well I don't know that we have any
questions while well we'll give people
just a couple more minutes I now have to
have body oh and I want to just make
sure that when people know that we did
that the national network of libraries
of Medicine in the Pacific South region
has worked with us to compile a list of
resources that they are updating in
response to the wildfires in northern
and southern California so there's a lot
of both the national information and
some key local county information that
people might want to take a look at so I
see a question from Alisha other than
joining the hint Alyssa how often people
become involved as volunteer librarians
needed for projects
oh right um I think what it is it's more
the mental we're trying to have more of
a mentoring sort of aspect so at the
moment we're just starting to build a
network so we've got people who've been
following on Twitter and who attended
the meeting and it's still very early
days but what we're trying to do is
develop the webinars so we're having
this one which is finding the evidence
and then small colleagues will be doing
different webinars throughout throughout
the year next year volunteer library so
we haven't got any volunteer librarians
in mind at the moment because it's such
a early days but it is something we
could find out whether there are any
projects that do need volunteer
librarians and who might which might
want to be want to mentor or remotely or
actually physically be then at something
I can ask see if there's any spread out
there any projects around
is it possible to record that make note
of the question from the person people
asking so I can email the response when
I found out more information yes yes we
grab these questions and also ELISA is
the librarian over at the National
Institutes of Health library so I can't
you can connect you after the meeting
for sure brilliant it was actually a
really good network of librarians which
has set up the international librarian
Network which is set up in America about
five years ago and it wasn't it wasn't
specifically associated 20 projects but
basically you have to sending your what
you explaining role a little bit you're
impressed work-related interests and
then they match you up with someone with
someone's in another country so that you
could mentor each other and see and
share experiences and it was really
fantastic and I'd like to see something
like that for this but unfortunately the
network stopped but they didn't map me
um Matt me till it's absolutely
wonderful and I would never met her but
we become good friends where email and
Facebook and you know she bounced ideas
offer each other I think something like
that would work really well
yeah she physically volunteering might
be a bit more difficult to support but
definitely sort of mentoring scheme
might work I should say as well from
from evidence side side we we have many
volunteers librarians working for us and
and we're always we wouldn't be able to
do what were able what we what we do in
terms of the evidence collections
without the support of volunteers both
enormous search side envy and the kind
of information specialist librarian site
and actually I think Alicia Alicia is
one of our volunteers so thank you very
much for doing that but we were always
we're always looking for people to to
support our work to to volunteering in
that way oh that's great Alicia you are
amazing aren't you so we are coming to
the to the end of our time and we made
it through the Hong Kong Thank You
Felice our IT support who has been
knocking box off our phone call right
and left throughout this whole meeting
we would be long gone without your
support so thank you for that if you
want to get one continuing education
credit for this meeting please fill out
the survey that I think Jen you can put
the URL for the survey into the chat box
and then once you fill out that survey
you go on to the Medical Library
Association learning catalog which again
there's a URL for that and enter the
code G is 1 1 1 8 and that will give you
one credit and a certificate should pop
up from that for this webinar thank you
so much to all of you for speaking
through this for our speakers Caroline
and then for joining us at what is may
be a difficult hour for you on your time
zone and we hope that all of you have a
happy end of the year we will be joining
you back again in 2019 with more
webinars but we're going to take
December off
so take care and thanks to everyone for
joining us thank you very much do you
really great thank you my pleasure thank
you very much indeed fatty weak